[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
Walter Martin did you know that the New
World Order is implemented
well it seems from the title
Davos World economic Forum Kings and
Merchants implemented
the New World Order are you trying to
imply that it's already implemented
we'll have to see so let's open with the
word of Prayer
our heavenly father
there is such important things happening
in the world and it goes by unnoticed
can you help us to uncover these things
and also Enlighten our minds and guide
our discussion in Jesus name amen amen
there are some
people pulling to the left and some
people pulling to the right
some people accusing
and the others accusing back again
but I think they're sitting at one table
what do you think I agree with you you
know what there's a lot of smoke
and behind this smoke a lot of things
are happening that's how the hegelian
dialectic works and uh
so you might hear the one saying this is
the way it has to go
let's take a Tony Blair for example and
then you have a DeSantis saying dead in
the water it's not going to come here
but they all belong to strange societies
don't they so you see
you've there's been a lot of talk about
Davos in the
previously previous years
I didn't hear about it so much no
but how long has Davos been going oh for
a very very long time
so do you think if we hear now that they
talking about New World Order and all
these things what happened then
it's been a long time coming so let's
look at the game that they are playing
and see if we can glean something from
it
well here is an article about Davos and
it comes from January 2023
bigwigs returned to Swiss mountains amid
economic crunch
so this year's Forum will be the first
at its usual time in mid-January since
the outset of the covid-19 pandemic
it was canceled in 2021 and postponed to
May last year resulting in reduced
attendance it's scheduled to begin
Monday and will run through Friday so
that's history now already
and we said we're not going to talk
ahead of time yeah because then it's all
speculation
so we'll talk afterwards when it's still
all speculation it's speculation but
then they can speak for themselves they
can speak and lie for themselves yes
so the world economic Forum president
Borge brende I don't know whether I
pronounce that right I hope I violated
it because
they deserve their names to be violated
mine is constantly violated so why why
not violate this one as well
not that the economic headwinds hanging
over this year's events brande pointed
to record participation by at least 52
heads of state
and more than half of them from Europe
well that's just to show that it's not a
pie in the sky it's an important event
with all these bigwigs for sure and if
you take the ten toes
it's all very prophetic as well yes
so in the controls including president
Marcos Jr of the Philippines president
Gustavo Petro Colombia and president
of South Korea
several Biden Administration officials
including special presidential Envoy for
climate John Kerry our bones men I hope
he took some bones to throw them around
Director of National intelligent Avril
Haynes FBI director Christopher Ray U.S
agency for International Development
Samantha power U.S trade representative
Catherine Thai and just to mention
interesting even the FBI director yes
why why is it there why is he there
so Among The Business Leaders whose
attendance has been announced by the
world economic foreign
BlackRock CEO Larry Fink
Salesforce chair and co-ceo Mark benioff
and Bane and Company chairman gaddies
Morgan Chase CAO Jamie dimon
is also planning to attend according to
a report
other notable figures who will attend
are the Central Bank European Central
Bank president Christine Lagarde
international monetary fund managing
director crystalina georgieva
and it just goes on and on and on and of
course Al Gore
with these little climate change trumpet
that he unceasingly blows
he's been debunked so many times
but if you repeat a lie over and over
eventually people might just believe it
right yeah I know unfortunately maybe
most people because we've got a if you
look at the statistics
the minority is actually looking at the
real facts yes and I'm glad that they
have all the school children on board
now because they obviously know more
about climate change than the scientists
who oppose it no well if I might just
also intercede here we were talking
about earlier
when was it implemented when did this
all start well if you think we've spoken
about this many times but there was that
movie
inconvenience truth yeah or what no but
that was our goal but I mean a movie In
Like Flint or Owlman Flint yes in the
70s and the opening scene was about
climate change yes it's been coming a
long long time it has also been derided
by critics for hypocrisy because
dignitaries sometimes fly in on private
jets before pushing for policies to
counter climate change
now all of these important people they
also Finance Wars don't they yeah don't
these companies Finance Wars it's been
like that throughout the ages and they
throw all these bombs which don't
contribute to climate change at all no
and now you've got the rebuilding of
Ukraine that has to happen and who's
involved there how about how what carbon
footprint will that have yeah and the
same companies that we've seen here at
JP Morgan Chase BlackRock the same these
names all over the place pop up every
time okay now let's go to the world
economic Forum web pages and see what
they are reporting and here is their
Global risk report for 2023 and they
List the 10 top risks and here are the
risks for a two-year period and then of
course their 10-year period
all right Martin so the first one is the
cost of living crisis and I don't think
they care two Hoots about the cost of
living crisis because they are all well
capable of surviving it that's it
but the number two should probably be
their number one namely natural
disasters and extreme weather events
so we'll talk about natural disasters
and extreme weather events in a moment
number three is
geo-economic confrontation
and wouldn't I find geo-economic
confrontation very interesting
for example the Biden Administration has
said that South Africa must move away
from coal-based economies right yes
and so we have this load shedding at the
moment
where we don't have power in this
country for hours and hours and hours
every day
and they keep saying they will correct
it and then they make it worse
but thousands of trucks
are leaving with coal and transporting
it to the harbors where it goes to other
locations such as China or other areas
in the world
so the coal-based economy must stop in
this country
but obviously it's not going to stop in
other countries because why is it being
exported at the rate at which it is
being exported so here is something that
is amiss definitely I believe that South
Africa is going to be sort of a test
case what will it be like when an
economy of this size one of the largest
in Africa
will collapse as a consequence of these
activities I think I agree with you and
we've been a testing ground because load
shedding was implemented more than 10
years ago already it started and then it
was going okay for a while and now we've
been constantly on electricity load
shedding meaning that we don't have
periods that we mentioned we don't have
electricity
for more than a year straight on yes and
the entire economy is collapsing as a
consequence and they're talking about
Mega riots that are coming within this
life probably
so we're in for a lot of excitement what
about food supply
Farmers can't work I mean they we've
seen millions of chickens for instance
die because the fans that are supposed
to keep them cool and everything
and they can't irrigate they can't
irrigate all these big irrigation farms
at least electricity so we I think
what's on the horizon is scary all right
but it seems to me that many of these
things are planned and no matter what
Scandal hits presidents as long as they
get to ride in royal coaches it means
that their connections are pretty good
and then they've sandwiched it again
with number four failure to mitigate
mitigate climate change
it's erosion of social cohesion and
societal polarization
now it's interesting how the media
actually pushes this right
and the race issues and the Bible
clearly says that there will be ethnic
problems at the end
so everything that they are actually
putting here as a risk in the two-year
one for instance now it's all everything
that the Bible actually speaks about as
well yes
then we're going to have large-scale
environmental damage incidents
one they seem to know that this is going
to come now one of the reasons why
people can know that it's going to come
is if they plan it and if definitely
I I'm sure and it's interesting if you
look at the color of this of this table
the green on this every time is
something to do with climate yes and you
can see what is the majority of risks or
problems that the country the the whole
world
faces
then what is the solution
that's every time where it comes back to
failure of climate change adaption and
then they have a purple one here that's
interesting widespread cyber crime and
cyber insecurity
a class Schwab announced that a long
time ago already and we've seen some
interesting things happening the
grounding of all U.S airplanes
afterwards the grounding of all Canadian
airplanes
then we have natural resource crises and
large-scale involuntary migration
but it's nice how they choose these
words involuntary
well when actually the governments make
sure that it takes place voluntarily yes
now most of these large-scale
involuntary migration is because of
climate change again
of course yeah where does this all come
from I mean so Martin that's what they
expect in the next two years sounds like
Matthew 24. exactly so what are they
expecting in the next 10 years well the
next 10 years are very green exactly
that's the main focus so that is their
focus and they have a red and a purple
so let's have a look at that in the next
10 years there will be a failure to
mitigate climate change
that's because they want a failure yeah
failure of climate change adaption
natural disasters and extreme weather
events
biodiversity loss and ecosystem collapse
large-scale involuntary migration
natural resources crisis erosion of
social cohesion and societal
polarization
widespread cyber crime and cyber
insecurity
geo-economic confrontation
large-scale environmental damage
incidents
so we're going to have a blame game
it's your fault no it's your fault
and there has to be a reparation and
there has to be redistribution of wealth
and there has to be everything
associated with this entire uh man-made
calamity
so those are their risk factors and they
sound as we said like Matthew 24.
let's just get some
soberness into it again here's a quote
from manuscripts number one
of two selected messages page 52
climate change or deliberate
interference that is what we wrote
and see the storms and tempests Satan is
working in the atmosphere he is
poisoning the atmosphere
and here we are dependent upon God for
our lives our present and eternal life
and in being in the position that we are
we need to be wide awake wholly devoted
holy converted holy consecrated to God
but we seem to sit as though we were
paralyzed God Of Heaven wake us up
according to this quote made in 1890.
what is Satan going to do he's going to
poison the atmosphere and he's going to
bring about storms and Tempest right
and we are dependent upon God for our
very lives does that mean that people
will die like flies yes definitely
doesn't Messiah say that the people will
die like flies yes
and are we seeing increased deaths over
and above normal yes we're seeing all of
these things
and we have to ask ourselves is it just
Satan or is he using his agents no for
sure he's using his agencies human
agents aunties
to Fallen Angels do we know who his
agents are inside of governments and so
does the scripture Define who his
enemies are yes does he talk about the
Beast yes does he give us enough
parameters to Define who the Beast is
correct yes are the kings of the world
going to commit fornication with this
Beast are the religious systems of the
world going to commit fornication with
this Beast are the economic Powers going
to commit fornication with this Beast so
who are the Agents of Satan all of them
all of them all right didn't we just see
a long list we did and we can go into
more detail with it all right here's
another interesting graphic depiction if
you can call this conglomerate the
graphic depiction from the world
economic forum this is the global risk
report for 2023
and it has little blobs with different
colors and bigger blobs with
a certain annotations so let's have a
look at some of these we're not going to
go into this in detail
but obviously they say everything is
interconnected right all the crises are
interconnected
and one has to ask oneself
how do you disseminate information
in order to make people believe that
there is a crisis don't you use the
media
that's the main
source of getting it out into the world
all right so you have Meda and then you
have alternative media
now who do they supposedly war against
the alternative media because they say
that's disinformation all right is it
possible Martin that some of the
alternative media might actually be part
of the hegelian plan maybe there can be
someone in there yes so it's all very
confusing no you have to you have to be
very careful on how you
eat or go through all the um the
information absolutely so let's see what
their big problem is
well let's have a look
at their big blobs
here you have the erosion of social
cohesion
in other words Nation against Nation
Kingdom against Kingdom
ethnic group against ethnic group right
and that is connected to misinformation
and disinformation
then you have certain minor things like
widespread cyber crime cyber insecurity
digital power concentration adverse
outcomes of Frontier Technologies and
breakdown of critical information
infrastructure
basically that is cyber War
misinformation we have to control the
narrative correct so we must just be
clear misinformation according to them
or carrying according to whatever goes
against their narrative that is
according to them this information yeah
it doesn't have so if they have a lie
and even somebody else tells the truth
that this information because it's not
the same as this it has to be in line
with them so this is a very important
fact
information must be controlled we have
to ask ourselves why
because there's a certain message Martin
that has to go into the world
and if that message is perceived as
truth
then Satan and his cronies will lose
adherence yeah that's it they will so
this information has to become so Broad
that you can put everything into the
category of disinformation including
that which is truth and slap it that's
it okay
and that leads then to erosion and then
you have severe mental deterioration
does the drug World play a role in that
as well oh for sure because the most
stressed people become the more they are
going to take
substances in order to alleviate their
problem and then what do you do you do I
will show it in a future one but you go
the way that Oregon and Vancouver has
gone now you legalize everything you
legalize everything and Martin if he is
poisoning the atmosphere let's just drop
it there
and leave it
would you have to guard yourself against
such activities and what's the best that
we can do in an impossible circumstance
and environment to counteract poisoning
what is the best that we can do it's
what we put into our body ah we have to
be very careful what we eat and what we
drink and we have to eliminate anything
that can affect our minds because the
battle is for the mind oh yes definitely
and then Martin of course besides the
mental illness will have infectious
diseases will have chronic health
conditions we'll have collapse of public
infrastructure and services
if you have collapse of the medical
infrastructure and you have chronic
diseases then you have the perfect
recipe for the chaos that they want
exactly
how many millions of people
are going to suffer if there is a
collapse in the medical
system
all right that also comes back to what
you just mentioned about how important
not only what you put in but everything
that is going with the lifestyle
all right let's look at the other aspect
which they're talking about they're
talking about State collapse
and that is brought about by terrorist
activity by the use of weapons of mass
destruction
Interstate conflict and all of these
issues and they always have migration in
there as well so Martin
why would you want to collapse States
because they have to become something
else than what they were before right
you have to build back better exactly
and in order to build back better you
have to dismantle what there was before
this is all a plan
and it's all very interconnected so they
know how the plan works they've thought
this one through
like we've asked earlier isn't this plan
already implemented is it all in isn't
it already running like a well-weld
machine yes it's called The Art of War
yeah
and then Martin you have the collapse of
a systemic important supply chain
we're going to have a collapse of Supply
chains are they working at it
they're doing a good job right yeah I
mean just look at what happened in the
last days we're talking about food for a
long time already
and then we're going to have a debt
crisis and a cost of living crisis and
then boringly we're going to have the
natural disasters the biodiversity lost
the failure to mitigate climate change
and the environmental damage
now
does Satan love God's creation no does
he care if it gets destroyed no he hates
it
correct he wants to destroy he wants to
destroy it because he hates God and he
hates God's people Martin this looks
like a battle plan
of the enemy because they're saying what
the problem is going to be and they're
constantly saying the problem is not
going to go away because nobody's going
to do anything about it
but they are doing something about it
they're collapsing infrastructure on
purpose they're collapsing
Distribution on purpose they're
collapsing social coherence on purpose
they are pushing it in the media
constantly
this is a battle plan this is a battle
strategy
have we been warned about this strategy
yes
we have very profusely we just read a
quote
that was written more than 120 years ago
which tells us that this is going to
happen when there was not even a whiff
of a possibility that it was going to
happen
and yet it is being implemented to the
four yes
so let's go to a quote in the great
controversy to put this into context the
wicked have passed the boundary of their
probation now that hasn't happened yet
but they are on a high-speed train to
petition right
the spirit of God persistently resisted
has been at last withdrawn this will
happen soon
unsheltered by divine grace they have no
protection from the wicked one Satan
will then plunge the inhabitants of the
earth into one great final trouble
did we just see a battle plan for such a
time of trouble not one of those things
were positive Everything is Everything
is negative okay
as the angels of God cease to hold and
check the fierce Winds of human passion
all the elements of strife
will be let loose the word elements is
very interesting because you have social
strife
you have governmental Strife you have
the elements of nature let loose because
there will be calamities
the whole world will be involved in ruin
more terrible than that which Came Upon
Jerusalem evolved
so Martin this is a diversional tactic
Satan knows that this is going to happen
because he's going to implement it
and he has no choice because it's been
prophesied that doesn't mean God is
going to force his arm but just God is
revealing his strategy from the
beginning yes God is telling us this is
what Satan wants to do and he's going to
do it and he's already given us the
blueprint of how it's going to be and
they have the blame game
perfectly lined up yes it is the
inability of humanity to listen to the
environmental issues therefore we're
going to have this total collapse
and the culprit who sits behind it gets
scot-free
and if you point out the culprit that's
fake news exactly and hate speech even
and hate speech and it will be
criminalized yes
so let's say it before it gets
criminalized
yes
all right so here's a little summary of
what happened at the world economic
Forum this is an alternative news media
and Martin the lady responsible for this
wasn't she persecuted thereafter yes
when she went home back to the U.S
her name was already flagged just
because she attended and she had a
nightmare in customs and getting through
the airport and being searched and
everything she actually made a video or
two about that as well all right let's
hear what her summary of the issues and
then we'll look at them Morgan here in
Dava Switzerland and here's your day 4
recap of how they are implementing the
great reset agenda all across the globe
now first with climate change this is a
billion dollar industry that we are
talking about and with this we asked
them how are they going to implement
that carbon tax on civilians worldwide
and I didn't get many answers next they
are combining against disinformation by
having corporations like CNBC in the
Wall Street Journal present along with
hosting a panel with Brian stelter on
misinformation make that make sense also
under the guise of food insecurity and
ability they are pushing more non-meet
options including insects and research
on that to come also on top of all of
these things with the 2030 agenda they
are predicting that there will be Global
cyber attacks across the globe in the
next two years and also that the covet
pandemic is not over and there could be
more outbreaks coming very soon now what
we have learned while being here at the
world economic forum is no matter where
you are in the country the wef has
infiltrated every single civilian even
in America
well in our discussion now everything
that she said will let these people talk
for themselves all right so we'll have
them break it down let's start with our
favorite bonesman
John Kerry he looks as if the world's
troubles are on his shoulders so his
expression tells us that he doesn't have
much hope for the future right
let's see what he has to say why is it
that
allegedly wise adult human beings
CEOs some of them United States Senator
some of them a whole bunch of folks
want to ignore science and want to
ignore mathematics and want to ignore
physics and somehow cannot bring
themselves
to do what we need to do
and when you stop and think about it
it's pretty extraordinary
that we select group of human beings
because of whatever touched us at some
point in our lives are able to sit in a
room and come together
and actually talk about saving the
planet I mean it's so almost
extraterrestrial to think about quote
saving the planet if you said that to
most people most people they think
you're just a crazy tree-hugging Lefty
liberal you know do-good or whatever and
and there's no relationship but really
that's where we are
you look at what's happening with
species half the species of the planet
have been already killed
but damn it all we have to find a way to
to get really serious
about bringing the corporate world on
board
so how do we get there well the lesson
I've learned in the last year is
and I learned it as secretary and I've
learned it since reinforced in Spades is
money money money money money money
money money money
and I'm sorry to say that I mean yes
technology yes exciting new initiatives
yes organizing winning races politically
I mean what happened uh in in the
midterms in the United States is nothing
less than miraculous it happened because
young people voted and the second most
voted issue was climate when we first
came together at Davos in May and we
started to talk about the vision for
Gaia one of the things that I shared was
David rockefeller's vision for strategic
philanthropy which he bequeathed to the
David Rockefeller fund when he formed it
two things philanthropy philanthropic
Capital should take risks the second
thing is that we have a moral
responsibility to use philanthropic
Capital to find leverage in driving
changes and outcomes for the way forward
and Gaia reminds us of both of those
critical principles
foreign
he said it quite plainly that the
economic world must now step up to the
plate right money money money money
money money money
and they must play their role that's
fascism right yes so they want this
fascism
to be part and parcel of the way in
which they will manage Humanity in the
future
and we must never forget that that is
the preferred form of government of the
Jesuit order according to their own word
that's the preferred method of
governance for the New World Order yes
hidden of course yeah hidden of course
under uh social cohesion
and then you had the spokesperson for
the Rockefellers
and she ends up with Gaia she actually
spoke a lot more about Gaia so
everything is
are you interested in Gaia Martin not at
all no this goddess should have no place
in any Christian's life exactly so now
just look at it you've got this whole
mix-up of things and actually all this
climate change agenda is actually about
Kaya yes it's the worship of Satan yeah
and and when he talks when Kerry talks
about not listening to the science I
mean he's the greatest culprit of them
all when it comes to that because they
don't listen to the science because the
the real scientists thousands of them
that are actually involved in climate
change research
are saying this is a lot of nonsense and
then you take on top of it it's all this
cons everybody always says it's a
conspiracy theory if you talk about New
World Order or Elites wanting to run the
world but there he acknowledged it and
said we are a bunch of elite people that
have similar mindedness and we are the
good ones they are the bad ones and he
threw in the Democratic win in the last
election as if that was a victory for
climate change yeah well if you you take
it on the other side if the second most
voted thing was climate change in the
midterms
if that's true well it shows you how
they are succeeding
in what they want the world to believe
so what I actually wanted to say is how
many people believe that climate change
is surreal well they start with the
youth don't they yeah and our greatest
expert on climate change is greater
she has I mean years and years and years
of of research capacity behind her in
order to make the statements that she
makes but nevertheless let's not go
there the only thing is the sad thing is
that the majority their plan is working
because the majority of the world are
following their plan all right let's
watch the next speaker Brian stelter
didn't he work for CNN yes so and now
he's running this panel for this
information well the experts at it
though should be able to do well let's
listen to what he says
the clear and present danger of
disinformation is our conversation here
this afternoon it follows a session just
now about disrupting distrust and of
course those are connected so I hope
that's where we can start I'm Brian
stelter formerly of CNN now a fellow at
Harvard University let me briefly
introduce our panelists and since we're
being live streamed a reminder that the
hashtag is weft 23 we can try to put
some real information out into the world
to make up for all the crazy uh I think
that we we have sufficient data which
show that Ally sells much better than
the truth
and if we do not stop that then the
algorithms will simply work in the in
the direction of Better Business and
better profit and that that's behind our
our rules in Europe that we we wanted to
stop this trend so when it comes to text
which is much more sophisticated well
they have to work with the language
so I don't think the AI is still is
already mature enough to to be able to
disclose but this is just a matter of
time for hate speech well we need the
people who understand the language and
the case law in the country because what
qualifies as HP
illegal hate speech
which you will have soon also in U.S I
think that we we have a strong reason
why we have this in the criminal law uh
we we need the platforms to Simply work
with Mr language and to identify such
cases the AI would be too dangerous to
do that it was also striking as the Elon
Musk of all people defending the idea of
freedom of speech but not freedom of
reach recently when it comes to
algorithms
our message was clear we have the rules
which has to which have to be complied
with and otherwise there will be
sanctions that we worked with
knowledgeable people with the lawyers
with the sociologists who understood
that they have to
behave in some decent way not to cause
really big harm to the society I always
felt that this this notion of
responsibility was that so this is what
I don't feel from uh Elon Musk
personally
so they want to control information and
there will be consequences and they have
the rules
and they will implement the rules
and here's this interesting little
battle going on with Elon Musk wasn't he
recently with the Pope yes isn't this
part of the egalian dialectic definitely
swinging this pendulum like we've spoken
about many times but also interesting
they implementing this is the European
government implementing
the rules for social media yes and
interesting what she said to the guy
from the U.S the senator it will be
coming to the U.S yes of course it will
be coming to the U.S they have to
implement these things but Martin if you
go to the Bible
and you ask who the liar is it's very
plain he was a liar from the beginning
exactly so he's agents won't they be
Liars too exactly like father like son
isn't that so and so there you can see
you are of your father the devil and the
works of your father you will do
so this is exactly what we can expect so
the LIE becomes the truth and the truth
becomes the lie and you see it on both
sides yes
so we've had this quote many times but
it is so essential that people
understand what is going on it is part
of a policy to assume the character
which will best accomplish her purpose
this is Catholicism
but beneath the variable appearance of
the chameleon she conceals the
invariable Venom of the serpent
we are not bound to keep faith and
Promises to Heretics so she can lie she
can break promises she can do whatever
she wants
and she's going to rule the roost and
protestantism
is going to give their power unto the
Beast because the change
has not been on the part of the papacy
but on the part of protestantism
so Catholicism indeed resembles much of
protestantism that now exists because
protestantism has so greatly degenerated
since the days of the reformers
but here we have this chameleon with its
tentacles all over
so they also said that we have to change
our diets right and we will have to have
more insects in our diet and all kinds
of strange things did you know Martin
that many companies are already
introducing
insects in the form of Protein that's
all they said protein protein what is in
that food how important is it that we
start making our own food
essential is it is it wise to buy
processed foods in the world that we
live in do you know what's in there nope
no no 90 99 of us if you read a label
you don't even know what's going on on
that label so let's ask the world
economic Forum what we should eat
five reasons why eating insects could
reduce climate change
everything is climate change right you
have to have that's the that's the main
ball that you have to look out for
because everything will happen around
that remember that movie is silent green
well they soon turn us into cannibals as
well no you don't even know it well
don't they already add fetal products to
food to the food chain well to to get
taste and everything yeah
all right so what did they say edible
insects can produce equivalent amounts
of quality protein when compared to
animals at such a ridiculous statement
because an insect is an animal
it belongs to the animal world
so they better get another zoologist to
try and Define what an animal is for
them insects require less care and
upkeep than livestock we're actually
running out of protein
button would be run out of protein if we
combine grains and legumes and cannot no
insects are part of a virtuous Eco cycle
that's very interesting this circular
value chain will continue to help
decrease emissions
as disposed organic materials no longer
end up in landfills producing methane
and other harmful gases in the process
and then you can start small and work
your way up what is this a new thing or
have they been preparing Minds for it
for a long time or a long time
now this was in February 22 already on
the world economic Forum but even long
before that they've started with this
now isn't it interesting how they use uh
the stars of the world
the Hollywood crowd to further idea and
to implant an idea
so some of this Hollywood crowd Martin
is part of a greater
activity and they have been integrated
in all kinds of occult
agendas but let's not go there we've
spoken about that many times but the
fact of the matter is that they will use
people
of influence to influence Minds
so here we have a little video of one of
the Hollywood stars introducing this
concept this is a number of years ago
already so it's been coming for a while
more than five years I think we've shown
this as well before let's just sew it
again
the teeth oh wow take the fangs out
have you done this before yeah yeah I
think it's always been a part of the
diet the bugs but then I think there is
a truth to the survival during the war
of course people when people are being
starved they were able to survive
survive on things like this and they did
when was the first time you had
these books I first had them when I was
first in country crickets you start with
crickets yeah crickets in a beer and
then you kind of you know move up to
tarantulas
go ahead
how do you flip a scorpion
is
that good guys dinner
you want to go you want to share a
spider hot come on
here
well
the way that I feel about spiders
you won't get me close to that
all right here's an article
from January the 24th 2023 insects on
the menu as EU approves to
for human consumption
the maggot-like larvae of lesser
mealworms a type of shiny black beetle
and house crickets will become the third
and fourth insects that can be sold as
food for people in the European Union
eight more applications await approval
on Tuesday the EU gave the green light
to the sale of the larvae in powder
Frozen paste and dried forms the
Crickets can be sold as partially
defatted powder
and the reason is to curb climate change
it seems to be the reason for everything
right you will see there is not one
thing that a solution will not be
because of climate change so insect
protein could provide a cheap
alternative particularly in processed
foods modern
I think I'm going to move away from
processed food completely because it
doesn't matter if you eat potato crisps
if you eat
canned beans
you don't know what's in there you don't
know it's legal to put it in
all right a more likely role for insect
protein could be feeding it to livestock
button
what they are feeding livestock at the
moment already is already horrendous
so it might actually be an improvement
to feed them insects well free
free-range chickens in any case it bugs
so
as some mealworm and fly lava are well
suited to the process could effectively
recycle some of the vast quantities of
food wasted each year
do you like fly larvae
and you have being in arachnophobic
oh maybe I must I don't know there has
to be something happening in here for me
to do that well Martin have you ever
should go on the Rampage I know how to
keep you in check I just bring a spider
so Martin they don't only want to
control what goes into your mouth they
also want to control what goes into your
veins and what goes into your muscle
so let's listen to another secret
society member totally Blair
yeah well the the best way to maintain
political Focus because I mean the
reality is for the political debate in
many many countries now covert is
in the rear view mirror mirror I mean it
it isn't but believe me most the people
sitting at Downey street at the moment
are not talking about covid and
um
at the G7 and the G20
I think you won't get the focus you need
unless it's clear two things
one that there is an ongoing challenge
an opportunity and I think that is not
just about covert it's about the fact
that we are going to have a whole slew
of new vaccines injectables that are
going to deal with some of the the worst
diseases in the world that give us the
opportunity
to make big changes in the in the health
of the world and if you want the
politicians to focus they need to think
look this is coming down the track soon
because if you tell them about a future
pandemic they'll kind of go yeah maybe
someone else's problem but
you tell them actually in the next few
years you're going to have the
opportunity to make a big difference to
the Healthcare of your population that
will focus them but the second thing
they need is to focus on the on the
opportunities to change Healthcare that
have Arisen as a result of our
experience of covid because you know
when's all said are done it's it was
still a pretty remarkable operation by
the way you know sepi did a fantastic
job you guys deserve a lot of
congratulations for it but so I think
it's around things like how do you make
sure you get the right scientific
cooperation and the cooperation between
the regulatory authorities so in the
future you can clear things much faster
for example on the continent of Africa
if we had an equivalent to the European
medicines agency we're in an African
medicines agency that allowed you to
have one system one standard which
hugely changed the way that vaccines and
treatments are introduced in Africa I
think there's a huge impetus now for a
national digital infrastructure
digitization in healthcare is I think
one of the great game changers you know
we should be helping countries to
develop a national digital
infrastructure which they will need with
these new vaccines and then you know
finally it it's it's also about showing
people and showing the political
leadership that you can make a positive
difference To Your Health Care system by
adopting these measures because they've
got a they've got an impact Beyond any
particular disease and or or pandemic so
I think if you want to keep the
political focus and I agree it's vital
that you do you've got to show people
that this is a continuing issue right
it's not a future issue it's here and
now it's got a broad set of implications
and there are a set of solutions that
covert has taught us arising out of the
challenges of covid
to which if we apply the right political
will we can make our Health Care Systems
better not just for pandemic and disease
but more generally for the health of the
the population if you do that
um
if you do that they'll think they'll
votes in it and you know
there are votes in it they'll they'll
Focus yeah thank you
Martin
asclepius
the serpent with his fangs
that injects materials into you
I think I'd rather go the health reform
way
for sure and if we do that then we have
a protection
that is greater than anything that these
people can provide well it's interesting
that he's mentioning Africa why Africa
is it that Africa
didn't play the game as well as they
wanted it to do that's exactly I think
what happened and they wanted to play
the game better
now I live in Africa and I don't want to
play the game
I want to do it God's way
now tiny Blair has been very vocal on
these issues
and he's been very denigrating to those
that don't want to play the game in the
past in some of his speeches
and we always want to show that all of
these role players that are so important
they are all connected to the Vatican
great and Tony Blair in 2007 writers
reported that he converted to
Catholicism
from Britain's established church
anglicatechism to Roman Catholicism
the head of Britain's Catholics said on
Saturday for a long time he has been a
regular worshiper at Mass with his
family and in recent months he has been
following a program of formation to
prepare for his reception into full
communion formation
spiritual formation a Jesuit ideal
these people are all connected with the
papacy because they are the Agents of
the Vatican and they are implementing a
Vatican agenda that's it the New World
Order is a Vatican idea and it started
with Vatican II
so the Bible tells us that the whole
world will wander with an O
after the beast in other words they have
to receive the mindset of the Beast so
they have to be indoctrinated to think
like the Beast the battle is for the
mind that's why all the media Moguls
have to constantly go and visit the pope
to go and get their instructions besides
the instructions that they get from the
Jesuits and all of these cronies and
Knights of Malta and who they all are so
let's have a look at this battle for the
mind
but then you start to worry that your
boss will notice your Amorous feelings
when she checks your brain activity and
shift your attention back to the present
you breathe a sigh of relief when the
email she sends you later that day
congratulates you on your brain metrics
from the past quarter which have earned
you another performance bonus
you head home jamming to the music with
your work issued brain sensing earbuds
still in
when you arrive at work the next day a
somber cloud has fallen over the office
along with emails text messages and GPS
location data the government has
subpoenaed employees brainwave data from
the past year
they have compelling evidence that one
of your co-workers has committed massive
wire fraud now they're looking for his
co-conspirators you discover they are
looking for synchronized brain activity
between your co-worker and the people he
has been working with
while you know you're innocent of any
crime you've been secretly working with
him on a new startup venture shaking you
remove your earbuds
you may be surprised to learn that it's
a future that has already arrived
everything in that video that you just
saw is based on technology that is
already here today
we're not talking about implanted
devices of the future I'm talking about
wearable devices that are like fitbits
for your brain we can pick up and decode
faces
that you're seeing in your mind
simple shapes numbers your PIN number to
your bank account
it's not just your brain activity here
that we can pick up we can also pick up
your brain activity in different places
like as your neurons fire from your
brain down your arm and send signals to
your hand to tell you how to type move
all of that could be decoded through
electromyography and that's what you're
seeing here is a device now in the form
of a simple wearable watch that can pick
up that activity and one of the pivotal
Acquisitions of the field meta acquired
this company control labs in 2019
because major tech companies are
investing and helping to make these
devices
universally applicable as the way in
which we interact with the rest of our
technology what is it like to feel like
pushing a button without actually
pushing it that could be as simple as
hey I just want to move this cursor up
or move it left constant conversation
with the machine
this new form of control it requires us
to build an interface that adapts to you
and your environment while we can't
literally decode complex thought just
yet
there's a lot that we can already decode
that's quite relevant for the workplace
environment a simple wearable hat that
has embedded electrode sensors that
would pick up brainwave activity and
give a score between one to five to help
the employer and the employee know what
stage of alertness the person was
experiencing and whether or not they
were starting to fall asleep most people
are very comfortable with at least some
forms of human quantification in fact
it's become so widespread that most
people feel like there's not that much
to worry about when it comes to doing
something like monitoring your heart
rate
but it turns out that that kind of
technology in the workplace particularly
when it's used to monitor productivity
of employees where they're moving
throughout the factory floor whether or
not they're taking breaks or unscheduled
breaks is the kind of thing that
employees resist unionize against rise
up against and undermines morale
what we've seen consistently is
companies from Amazon to Tesco to
Walmart and others have introduce what
is considered to be bossware or
surveillance technology that employees
really don't like it even if
it makes their lives better
okay well if you don't like your job
just quit
but what if there's nowhere to go
what if everywhere has ubiquitous
monitoring in fact during the pandemic
what we found was that 80 percent of
companies admitted that they use at
least some forms of so-called bossware
technology to monitor the productivity
of their employees the newest way to
monitor attention is through a device
like this one
these are ear pods that are launching
later this year these ear pods much like
the video you watched earlier
are ear pods that can pick up brainwave
activity and tell whether or not a
person is paying attention or their mind
is wandering okay well you might think
fine but even if we can tell whether a
person is paying attention or their mind
is wandering you can't tell what they're
paying attention to
you would be wrong turns out that you
can not only tell whether a person is
paying attention or their mind is
wandering but you can discriminate
between the kinds of things that they're
paying attention to whether they're
doing something like Central tasks like
programming
peripherals has like writing
documentation or unrelated tasks like
surfing social media or online browsing
when you combine brainwave activity
together with other forms of software
and surveillance technology the power
becomes quite precise and how do you
decode somebody's pin number you flash a
series of numbers and see how their
brain reacts to them so you have
recognition memory signals that are
pre-conscious and subconscious and this
is part of why it's been used for
example by governments to interrogate
criminals do you recognize this
potential co-conspirator do you
recognize
um you know this murder weapon those
pre-conscious signals like what we call
the p300 wave or the n-400 wave these
are before you even consciously process
information so you could prime it with a
number and then see if a person
recognizes it and you can do it without
them realizing that that's what you're
doing so will all of our passwords be
cracked first by this or Quantum
Computing hard to tell all right I think
we're moving past passwords pretty
pretty quickly
the world economic forum is very busy
isn't it and what I like about well I
can't say like but what's interesting
about what you said in the beginning
this technology is not future it's
already here all right now
can Satan read your mind no no he cannot
can God read your mind yes yes
does he covet that ability for sure
so now he's working on ways to see what
you are thinking
uh didn't we just recently talk about
the lady that was arrested for what she
was thinking exactly now you're gonna
wear a smart watch and they can
pick you up just like this so they can
actually see what you are thinking they
want to know what you are thinking can
you see how clever this is poker is
going to be a thing of a blast
uh that poker face is gone now that
poker face is gone but look how clever
they are
they've started with the technology of
smart watches and fitbits and all this
stuff
so long so now it's part of your daily
life isn't that part of your cell phone
already already so they listen to what
you say don't don't all of these things
appear in the media and everybody says
Ah you know so what so what I
a saint of all companies has imp that
employ
during the pandemic 80 percent
so do you think this is going to change
in the future you know Martin I've come
across people
even within the religious sphere that
want to put spyware on other people's
computers to see what they are doing it
is so disgusting to me that I cannot
even believe that someone who has just a
vestige
of morality in them would want to do
something like that can't you see where
it comes from
who's the big guy behind this you just
mentioned it who's coveting to know what
you think
all right there are of course uh you
know things where you want to know what
is happening when it comes to
criminality and things like that
but uh where technology like this can be
useful like this case in the United
States where this person supposedly
stabbed those four individuals and uh
very sad story and it speaks of very
perturbed Minds sick Minds
and our technology was used to arrest
the suspect but we're not talking about
that we're talking about
your moral compass
has anybody the right
to accuse you
for your moral compass
in other words if I believe the Bible
and I believe what the Bible says
will I then become the Enemy of the
State
and will I become the enemy of the
system
because the the state and the system are
not on the side of scripture they're on
the other side of the coin
and even if the pendulum swings and they
move to the point where they accept the
morality of scripture they won't
actually do it they'll accept the
morality of the Beast that
pretends to be the spokesman for
scripture but in actual fact hates it
yeah and you know what one of them
entering wages will be comfort
where Satan will catch you because this
will make everything a little bit easier
these types of
things that they can control you more so
when you when it's
um comfortable for you and it makes your
life easier you probably go with it even
if it's a little bit against your morale
I would never want to go along with it
how can how can somebody surveying my
very thinking make me feel comfortable
it would make me feel extremely
uncomfortable so those earbuds or
whatever they've shove into your ears
I'll make sure they don't go into mine
no if I can possibly help it if you can
but the world economic forum is not done
yet let's listen to the next
contribution
all right we're talking about Davos so
let them tell us something more here at
weft I believe we're discussing
um there's a lot of discussion about
what the the New World Order will be I
hope this time round once we're building
this new world order when I'm looking at
this it's a grid infrastructure Yeah so
basically the way it works is it's 170
kilometers long 200 meters wide 500
meters high virtually no traffic you can
go to different places very efficiently
without using cars there are no Cars not
one single car it's it's going to be
different types of Transportation it is
a basically biological tip that it is in
the tablet and once you take the tablet
and dissolves into your stomach sends a
signal but you took the tablet
so imagine the applications of that
compliance the insurance companies to
know that the medicines that patients
should take they do they take odds in my
view are better than 50 50 that there
will be a coveted scale problem within
the next 15 years of the land and
creating the droughts and melting the
ice and raising the sea level and
causing these waves of climate refugees
predicted to reach 1 billion in this
Century look at the xenophobia and
political authoritarian trends that have
come from just a few million refugees
what about a billion we would lose our
capacity for self-governance on this
world we have to act
perhaps Martin we should say nothing we
don't have to they said it all they said
it all just listen to them
and uh you know you know the way they
speak that's the thing and what about
you know how many people would say yes
but a lot of these things that they are
talking about are good ideas
what do you say about that did Mussolini
have good ideas
did Stalin have good ideas
they spoke in a similar fashion didn't
they
and surveillance surveillance
surveillance Martin
if you constantly want to survey that's
what it started with Herod already
who had the greatest surveillance system
of his time
and how anybody that opposed him or his
regime
was dragged through the streets and
mutilated
so Martin where did all of these things
begin yeah because this is a new world
order a new idea that's just been
implemented now every Pope has spoken
about it in the last few years since
since Vatican II in 1962
all right let's have a look at the
situation from even those that are
unhappy with what is happening in
Catholicism even within Catholic circles
yeah they are Catholic they are the
Roman Catholics yes the more
conservative wishing for the old
Catholic Church free Vatican twos let's
listen to what they say
The Missing Link surfaces at last new
video of Klaus Schwab of the world
economic Forum connecting the dots
between revolution in the Catholic
Church 60 years ago and the great reset
why did they get rid of Pope Benedict
and install Jose Mario bergoglio to the
chair of Saint Peter and what's the
connection between the global lockdowns
of today and a bizarre middle of the
night ceremony that took place some 55
years ago deep in the catacombs beneath
the streets of Rome 92 year old father
Luigi batazzi is the last known Survivor
of a secret pact that experts say may
have influenced Pope Francis signed 50
years ago at the time of Vatican II by
Catholic Bishops in this underground
Church in Rome
called The Pact of the Catacombs it
vowed to create a poor church for the
poor the same church quote Francis says
he wants today I always say that Pope
Francis is the new catacombs pact and
they decide for example to decide uh
to refuse for example to be called
eminency Monsignor so they wanted to be
called like father and we can say for
example that uh
they decide to refuse all the Insignia
okay and when I say Insignia it means uh
uh like the no yeah the cross the Rings
yeah not them yeah this included
obviously doing away with the papal
Tiara or the crown the symbol of the
Pope's ruling Authority which has been
there for a thousand years from 1143 in
fact to 1963 the papal Tiara was
solemnly placed on the Pope's head
during the papal coronation Pope Paul VI
was crowned Pope he wasn't inaugurated
he was crowned and they got rid of that
institution of the monarchy at every
level in the Catholic confessional
States for the 100 years before that and
finally they got rid of the idea of
crowning the pope he no longer was a
monarch he was more like a president
which is exactly where they wanted it
so in 1964 Pope Paul VI renounces that
crown and the popes have never been
crowned since
and after his Mass we're talking about
Francis now after his massive
Inauguration in 2013 he said that he
wanted a poor church for the poor people
remember this
foreign
quote we will do our utmost so that
those responsible for our government and
for our Public Services make and put
into practice laws structures and social
institutions required by Justice and
charity equality in the harmonic and
holistic development of all men and
women and by this means bring about the
Advent of another and new social order
end quote
also known as the New World Order
Bishop Helder kamada or Kamara into
anglicize it the self-identified
Socialist Archbishop from Brazil whom
Francis would declare a servant of God
in 2015. he is the role model of one
Jorge Mario bergolio it was Archbishop
Kamara who on November 16 1965 LED 42
powerful counsel fathers Bishops down
into the catacombs to sign the catacombs
package a bit more on that they also
vowed to put pressure on International
organizations to help change the
economic structures which they said
exploit the poor these are all points
that are remarkably similar to Pope
francis's agenda for the church today
he's got one more point on his resume
he was a major influence on a young
Klaus Schwab
I I give you one example which for me
was probably a crucial moment in my life
I traveled for the first time to Brazil
I met a priest
who was known at that time as a priest
of support people
his name was Don Elder hamara and he
brought me to the farvelias of Recife
and I was so shocked and I said I have
to invite
this bishop to Davos to tell the people
what poverty is so I invited him to know
to to the annual meeting in Davos but
sometimes I came back in Switzerland I
found out
that actually he was forbidden at that
time to speak in Switzerland because he
was considered to be a communist and I
said this is for me a test but son I
noticed that many companies told me if
you invite this person who is so much
against business
we will not come to doubles anymore
and that's
where I had to stand to my values yeah
even at the risk that I would have to
give up uh was the world economic form
wow
um but it went very well I have to say
um the audience in Davos listen to him
and they also vowed to put pressure on
International organizations to help
change the economic structures which
they said exploit the poor these are all
points that are remarkably similar to
Pope francis's agenda for the church
today it's the same Revolution it's the
same players in fact the great reset was
indeed hatched in a catacomb beneath the
streets of Rome with the close of the
second Vatican Council in 1965. it just
took a while to get to the point
politically where it is now but it's the
same movement
Martin it actually comes from a little
bit earlier novarum
Catholic Social Doctrine
the world has to be restructured
so what we've seen now is that the world
economic forum is nothing other
than the organization that is to drive
the papal agenda that's it
and it is part of the healing of the
wound
up until that time of Vatican II the
papacy and the rest of the religious
World protestantism in particular were
divided
the papacy was seen as the Antichrist
had been identified by the reformers
that picture had to change
and therefore she took the shape of a
chameleon that's it changed her colors
and went underground
into the catacombs and made this
so-called pact which is actually part of
the plan a long time ago because the
devil is not divided against himself
so this Antichrist system had to
popularize itself to the world and throw
off the old image that it had
so this ruling power this
Monsignor
this ultramontanist
had to be seen as a man of the people
and no longer as the ruling power
that ruled over the world with tyranny
in the past
so it changed its approach but
underneath
it is still the Venom of the serpent
that is working Davos
the world economic forum is nothing
other than the plan of the papacy to
receive its power back yes and the world
will give their power unto the Beast so
Martin it is part of our policy
to assume the character which will best
accomplish a purpose
but beneath the variable appearance of
the chameleon
she conceals the invariable Venom of the
serpent she is Antichrist
today
she wasn't in the past and she will go
to Perdition
and those that align themselves the
Protestants
the Beast and the false prophet will be
thrown into the Lake of Fire
button do you want to end up in the lack
of Fire
I certainly don't but it's a stat state
that our own people that have this book
and all these books the spirit of
prophecy books and you have the Bible
that this book con gives you
confirmation about this prophecy we'll
turn around and say
no
all right now let's just take another
point
once the world gives the power unto the
Beast
that means the Beast rules again she
will be like she was in the Middle Ages
do we see that she wants to persecute
and control
oh you must just put it in your mind
it's now a Fitbit and now your mind is
doing something it's not supposed to
what is going to happen to you
you're gonna get
first slammed over the film you're gonna
get persecuted yeah so let's get the
message out do not accept the mark of
the beast do not follow the system it is
demonic it is from the pits of hell
but the kingdom of God will not be
shaken because the Gates of Hell will
not Prevail against them take your stand
on the side of the Lord and keep the
Commandments of God hold to the
testimony of Jesus and renounce the
system which is from another source
let's pray
Heavenly Father
you have predicted all of these things
that are happening before our eyes
and people believe the lies and follow
the system
help us to understand give us I solve
that we may see is my prayer in Jesus
name
amen amen
[Music]
thank you